today as a sober person I'm gonna taste
junk food
I'm sorry it's called a turd dog I
didn't say like a minute how many
different animals are in this can we
just look at how gross this is yeah it
literally looks like a poop with like a
little bit of semen like pouring out of
the side I find the like ground be mixed
with the hotdogs in the bacon and the
cream cheese kind of a really nice
flavor if I could buy these frozen I
would this is like when you leave the
club and there's like a sausage vendor
and you order like seven sausages and
you just go in on it oh that smells like
the bathroom at like the bond my breath
will be so hot what is I feel like I'm
gonna need to go straight to the
bathroom it's like this is not is
diarrhea I think all the meat is at the
bottom so I think I'm just gonna take a
huge bite out of the bottom okay
oh-oh-oh-oh
maybe it's because I'm Asian but I'm I
don't mind the spam I don't like this
amazing this is the way to a woman's
heart I feel like this is a lunch that I
would eat if my mom was drunk there's a
lot textures and don't go together like
cranky but salute I like it I think this
is where stoned people meet drunk people
yeah this is their beautiful love story
this has everything that makes like a
well-balanced flavor you have the salt
you have the sweet and you have the acid
of the Apple I read this in a cookbook
it's something that I wouldn't eat in
public I mean on the bright side after
the sauerkraut I think we deserve to get
to eat candy well I like cake and I like
candy so I don't see how we can go wrong
there's some conflicting flavors going
on did you put gum in this sour patch
kit really gummy bears M&Ms okay we
should species right
I would eat this in any plane of
existence but I worry for the person
Medina's who's drunk because it involved
oh yeah an oven while you're drunk
that's a bold ass move like the
microwave yeah but nothing else don't
[ __ ] with an oven when you're drunk